Tiffany i'ma start with the picture
you're an animator but you're one of I
think over a hundred how many total 130
painters so tell me first how you became
involved with the project with that many
painters I believe brought from all over
the world was there an audition process
in essence or was it so basically I
worked on the film from May it's the
beginning of November and of October
through November last year and I just
saw ads for it on Facebook and
everywhere and I saw the project and I
thought you know this is amazing it's
totally I studied animation in school
but I loved you know I also do
traditional fine art hand painting with
other side with oils so I thought how
cool would be to work in this project
and I applied no Sun in my portfolio
didn't really they get here back one of
those projects where you go oh it's
really cool but of course I'm not you
know I'm not that's too cool for me so I
actually didn't hear back for two months
and then the magda the production
coordinator contacted me and she goes
well we really like your work and we'd
like you to come to Pullman to test for
the film yeah well okay that's awesome
but I have to fight a Poland so I did
end up flying there I made a decision in
about two and a half weeks it's very
spontaneous and I flew there on May 21st
and I tested as a three-day test and it
was the hardest test of my life I
studied animation in college at USC but
I'd never done anything like frame by
frame painting hand-painted animation so
it was definitely new for me and you
know I really didn't think I passed but
I did end up passing I'm gonna have to
let you two go through two weeks of
training before you're officially on
production so that's the process so
again you seem frame by frame
and you're using oils so what were your
tools that you were that you handed and
what did how were you given since you're
one of a hundred and thirty how were you
given the style and or the look of the
film to follow so to answer your first
question we just had brushes and royal
talons paint
and credits a total of 6,500 tubes were
used of paint and yeah 1300 liters I
believe so quite a lot of paint and
those of Van Gogh paints which are
excellent paints and we just use a
variety of brushes um you know whatever
is seen me got you decide what brushes
you need all those supplies were given
to us we're in charge of mixing our own
paints and let your second question
basically we're given design paintings
to paint our scenes so about four years
before you know they have these amazing
design painters that break down the film
and they create these paintings based on
Van Gogh's original paintings too you
know set the look of all the distinct
locations in the film and then they
would give those to us painters along
with original van Gogh references and we
would look at that and work with the
director director works with each and
every one of us and we paint the first
frame we send it to the director dodaf
for approval and it's sort of this back
and forth you know getting that look
right before you start animating but
there are design frames painted by
painters and of course original van Gogh
painting so that's really what we had
they mentioned live-action reference
that they shot some live-action
reference yes did you get to see that or
that was shot way before so you had to
work with with basically just look at
the character yes yes so they shot at
the whole film in two weeks in London
this was way before I was brought on a
few years before I think something like
that and then yeah so basically us
painters I don't know if you guys have
seen pictures of the pas stations but we
have our own little station and there's
a camera that projects the live action
however you guys might think you know
like this is just straight up Brutus
hoping it's not because we did have the
the vague reference of the actors you
know acting but a lot of it shot on
green-screen so it was up to us painters
to recreate the backgrounds based on the
design paintings none of that was
provided for us is not
it's not in the original references of
the live action everything was mostly
shot on green-screen
so we had to create you know the
backgrounds the you know landscapes a
lot of times when it's not an event
opening you know we work with Dorota to
go how would this look in this
particular shot or angle so that that
and that aspect we had a lot of artistic
so your pet but you're painting on a
canvas yes you paint on about three feet
by two feet canvas so it's in your room
so we have a little each have a little
station and it's this canvas of a
computer right in front of us so we work
with dragon frame so you paint every
other frame you take a picture scrape
off the whole frame or part of the frame
depending on how much movement there is
paint the next frame so every third
first third fifth seventh so on yeah but
it's all so every time you make a new
frame you're destroying the frame yes
you're destroying the painting so you're
basically painting each new frame
however many scenes you know yeah you
know shots and things have you know um
150 frame to 600 frames you know
so you're basically repainting each
frame on the same canvas the hardest
part was probably scraping off
everything getting it clean so that
you're the next painting you do this and
it's not muddled and doesn't have the
previous you know colors because we have
a rule that you know oil paint gets dry
so you have to scrape off every third
frame no matter what eve you know
depending even if there's little
movement or a lot of movement so they're
very strict on that because when it
dries it doesn't look good it says let's
go onto to the sound for a while first
of all how did you become you've done a
lot of live-action you work with there
I've been offski Black Swan and requiem
for a dream could you talk about how you
became involved with this project yeah
Dorota who wrote the script and directed
the film with with her husband Hugh had
started this journey if you like in 2008
she had put together this idea and that
she wanted to do she was gonna hand
painted all herself I think at first
once you do this short and
hand-painted on itself there pango Hugh
had won an Oscar in 2008 for a short of
Peter and the wolf
so so Dorota contacted him and sent him
his stuff because she thought he might
be you know open to it and he saw it and
he thought it should be a feature you
know there was more going on here than a
short so they sort of started that that
journey you know in 2008 and when Dorota
was right in the script she said that
she didn't listen to any other music but
mine and she had given the producers I
guess you know a bit of a heart attack
by refusing to even discuss the option
of somebody else score and it except for
me
which you know is amazing it's like a
real real honor you know that somebody
felt that strongly about my work you
know but this project kept coming up and
I must admit I'm gonna you know sounds
terrible I couldn't really get my heart
my my head around it at first you know
and I had it came up at a time but did
she first contact you I can't remember
but it was probably about four years ago
I think when he first started coming up
and then I I play live shows with a nine
piece band performing my film scores you
know and um Ivan who's one of the
producers came to a show in London in
2014 that was and that was the first
time I thought okay I can't even I spoke
to him I kinda get it you know but then
I met with Hugh and Dorota about a year
later the following August I think he
was that had been in the October of the
period of 2014 and I I met with them in
August of 2015 so I they showed me then
some rough footage of the live action
stuff and then the first lot of stuff
that actually had had some painting done
to it so I could sort of okay I get it I
get it you know I sort of see what's
going on now and then but I'd read the
script and it had this sort of
murder-mystery vibe about it and you
know obviously a lot of speculation but
it just held together really well I
thought and
as I said I mean I don't if I said no
I'm not doing it and only Dorota would
have accepted that anyway I think I'd
have had to have done it rather wanted
to or not you know well thank you very
much for your work thanks for having us
thank you